so this is the last one and so what's
that like is it emotional or is it just
kind of another thing no
it was terrible it was terrible the i've
started recording woody in 1991 that's
when we
actually got together do the first one
guess he wasn't born then i'm going to
say half of it
everybody to my left was not yet
conceived
really you were born i was having sex i
and think are my parents
well we've painted a picture now thank
you yeah meanwhile back in your last oh
well
it's a long time well and you you record
these things over about four years
um you go in about every eight months
and and deliver up under
everything that the writers have come up
with and and the last session was uh
i thought it was just odds and ends you
don't have to do a little bit of this
reel a little bit of that maybe one
whole
sequence but i was in the same studio in
the same microphone
with the same glass studio b at disney
and when they
they they said okay great thanks
and just like that 20 however many years
were over and i had to say wait guys
guys guys
there's got to be there's got to be
something else you need no we got pretty
much got it all no
no no no no no no there's got to be a i
got to say come on guys or i got to say
something like
let's get back to bonnie's room or
lookout buzz there's got to be some line
i said no you're done and my little oh
started equivalent i had to you ever do
this when you're really uncomfortable
and all you can do is say
well oh my oh my my
oh my my my my well well well well oh my
god
oh my and the only thing to do was to go
and get in my car and drive away and i
was you know i heard the music and the
sun was going down in my mind's eye i
was like
the
someone would have got a you know party
popper or something for the egg
i think they were really celebrating the
end of some other people's work
are you very nervous jack whitehall
joining a big disney franchise like
frozen
yes so frozen i was very excited
when the call came in because i'm a
massive disney fan and frozen called me
up they said we're making this film
and we'd love you to be a part of it i
was like yup sign me up which princess
am i playing
and i i played a troll in the film i had
one line
in the film but i was like yeah i'd love
to do it i learned my line i
i i went in i absolutely i'm not nailed
it i nailed it absolutely
it was so good and then i told everyone
that i was in frozen i did a press
junkie in front of the poster
i was so excited and then six months
later popped on the black tie went down
to the odeon in putney it wasn't a
premiere it was a mistake
i watched the film got to the end and
the line wasn't there
so i called my agent i was like there
must be some kind of mistake this must
be some different director's cut that
i've seen
and she went oh no i forgot to tell you
i got an email about this um they said
that they have reduced your part in the
film
to a non-speaking role
in an animation
the worst thing is that it then becomes
the biggest film ever i love the film
and every time i watch it it's like
getting an icy dagger to my heart
song as well it's like they're heckling
me let it go
no i won't but is your character still
in it
yes you can see the character and he
goes through it from his mouth and then
it cuts
loki the troll
fantastic because you and are you
working with a frozen yeah yeah
yeah i just work with josh um
yes and on uh on a beauty and the beast
for disneyland you're doing beauty in
the beast
you are really good at rubbing it in
this evening
yeah they're not cutting out lumiere
lumiere's in yeah
i'm tara the friend i i've been living
with a friend i'm married to a french
woman
20 years more than 20 years and um i
thought yeah i can do the french accent
i got there and i couldn't
[Laughter]
that's what i did and they said no don't
do the don't do the her they didn't want
the french
her so when you take the french and you
do an er
you suddenly become totally mexican
we are a guest vr again service to the
test
and behind the glass i can see them all
going okay just wait a minute
i'll work on it because of course you
louis you were in um
cars too what amusing character did you
play in cars too
uh myself but i had to do it in
several languages why i like had about
three lines and i didn't afford
different languages
so it was just a conversation with um
mcqueen
it's really cool so i didn't spanish
german and french
in english now and have you seen the
film oh yeah of course you're sure
you're in it because i couldn't
and i was on the only cars i didn't blow
up so i'm hoping to come back for number
three oh
cars three bigger park nice exactly nice
i am i do love disney but i the other
reason that
disney has now ruined for me is because
i went to the disney hotel have you ever
been to the disney hotel
i was doing work in america i was there
for a month and i love disney but it's
to disney
there's like disney everywhere disney
wallpaper music
yeah it's for kids i was working for the
disney corporation so i think they're
trying to save some money i'm not a
weirdo
but they also have disney staff members
so like characters so
like goofy's doing teppanyaki in the
restaurant you get a wake-up call it's
daffy duck's voice
um
they're walking around the hotel but the
moment that my childhood died was like
i think it was about two weeks in i was
very tired and alone i was in my room
and i called down to the front desk and
it was mickey mouse's voice
it's like hey hey hey buddy what can i
do for you today i was like
mickey i need to activate the pawn
channels on my tv
it's a sad
[Applause]
but you moment must have been quite a
cool dad because of your disney
associations
yeah yeah i was a moana dad for a while
yeah you wrote the music from moana yeah
yeah yeah
but the thing is that's got to get your
brownie points at home it does and that
was his first movie so it was a lot of
you're welcome
around the house and you know i mean
that's the kind of song you can only
write for dwayne the rock johnson
because
only he could get away with it and
you're like what a charming man
uh he's the only person who could pull
off he is an amazing character you've
just worked in there i did just work
with him yes
yeah we did we just had dinner with him
last night it was really fun what does
the rock eat
well it's sort of like gruel sort of
hash like it was combination it was very
different from what we were eating yes
what was that well you sort of had one
big
cheat night a week yeah yeah he sat yeah
because when he worked with me he didn't
he was like he was burning calories
while eating lunch and he would just he
would sort of stand and eat
this giant chicken i was like do you
want to sit and he was like nah man i'm
good
but last night he relaxed yeah yeah yeah
for his part loves tequila though
oh does he oh yeah oh good old rock yeah
absolutely good old rock i don't know
why i dropped the the but anyway
i know him so well i just got him wrong
and uh emily uh uh more in terms of uh
your children your children encouraged
you to get involved in animation to do
voice work didn't they
well didn't you no you're was it your
son my son loved
finding nemo my son's first word was
nemo
which is a quite bad reflection of me as
a parent says there's a lot of sitting
in front of a telly
because i did actually love finding nemo
i think finding him as one of the best
films
but i did work out quite early on that
he was sort of hypnotized watching it
and it would be quite good to sort of
just shove him in front of it for hours
of time
and so his first word was nemo and then
about six months later i put nemo on for
the hundred thousandth time and he said
not [__] nemo again
oh funny but then but then you said yes
to cars
i did yes how do you know so much about
them it's like i've read about you
i'm i'm a holly shift well yes you are
absolutely
well the police shift well yeah she
seems like such an adult
name to give a character in accordance i
know it's not
sort of kinky isn't it it is ollie shift
well yeah would that would be right
saying your sexual awakening
was was sort of was a two-dimensional
sexual awakening oh god
um no it's true i i was once interviewed
when i was like you know who were
your first crushes and and um and i did
i i loved the lion king when i was
younger and i had a weird obsession with
nala
[Applause]
look at her face she's so sweet
but she can sing really well that's
wrong that is so wrong
and is it true you like made marion as
well yes that is true she's a fox though
oh this oh no no no but in eddie's
in his defense they drop them really
sexy
there he is and that tunic is worn very
low i know this
yeah he's packing do you get sort of
children wanting you to
kind of delight them as as maui all the
time
all the time like it's constant it's
always constant oh you sing
songs sing your song sing your song and
i do it and then
and then they cheer and then i go hey
okay we'll have a good day and then
sing again
yes he has a great voice saying oh thank
you you should sing to them
that looks like a man who wants to i
don't i don't know all right let's see
what's the music you want some music
just go right into the wrap part and
this is what the kids love so it's all
right listen kid
honestly i could go on and on i could
explain every natural phenomenon
the tide the grass the ground oh that
was maui just messing around i killed in
the airline i buried its guts sprouted
the tree now you got coconuts
what's the lesson what does it take away
don't mess with maui when he's on a
breakaway
and the tapestry here on my skin is a
map of the victories i win
look where i've been i make everything
happen look at that me mini man we just
take it to tapping
you